you are making your hosting debut you've
done so much
does this in any way make you nervous is
like how are you feeling about this i am
very nervous i just don't want like to
stutter
i don't want to stutter and then on top
of that i feel like being so close then
grew to covet
and not doing shows and not being um in
front of the camera for a long time like
i am really really nervous and i was
like oh this could be easy it's not like
i'm doing a performance and i gotta
learn all these dance moves but it's
like wait a minute why i feel just as
nervous as if i'm doing a performance
like this don't make no sense well
because you kind of are but but the one
thing like you can always rely on is you
know how to make an entrance better than
anybody else and so that's the thing
that's what it is that's the thing of
the host you definitely do so what are
you hoping to bring to the stage when
you make that entrance i mean is it one
of those things where you cannot miss
the beginning give me fashion yes
[ __ ] it's gonna be hey
i just wanna be like a party i like
parties you're up for three more uh
nominations this year how does it feel
to get recognized yet again i haven't
even been focusing on like oh am i gonna
win am i gonna lose am i gonna do this
because i just been so focused on like
hosting and
i just don't want to come off as corny
like i don't want it to be courtney like
imagine if i make a joke and nobody asks
i like corny though i'll be
yeah laughing imagine all right so
imagine if you make a joke that you
don't even laugh
like i i'm scared of that
well practice on offset i'm sure he and
and the kids i'm sure they'll be a good
audience for you to practice
he's a sagittarius that serious people
think that nothing funny right they did
nothing funny
well then there you go if you make him
laugh then you're like oh damn i got it
then i'm gonna make everybody laugh if
he actually laughs will you bring
culture and and your son with you and
often are they gonna be watching or will
culture get on stage at all we see her
no i didn't because i just felt like the
flight it was just so inconvenient and
my baby's too little right now for a
plane i think oh he's good though right
baby boy's good yeah he's good so let's
talk about the fashion because you know
the hosts always have to have a ton of
outfit changes so what are you going to
be giving us during the show as far as
the fashions go i'm going to be giving
you couture
okay so how many outfits can we plan on
because we'll be counting i think i
think like seven okay today i'm doing
the fittings it's definitely like seven
and that's another thing that i'm
overwhelmed about it's just like the
little bit of time that we have to
change and like it's the hair
salah when we dream make a stream adam
you've already made history at the amas
because you became the first female
rapper to ever win favorite hip-hop song
and you've done that twice actually so
what was that like winning the award
what was that moment like for you you
know i'm always thankful when um
when i when i win an award
any award you know what i'm saying
because it's just like sometimes you
know
nowadays with social media everybody
just have different opinions and
sometimes no matter if a hundred
thousand people are saying that they
like it it could be two three people
they're saying the nasty thing and it
just like make you feel like am i doing
enough am i doing enough and like when i
get these awards you just show like fans
and people in the industry think that
that song is that girl so when i get a
war it's just a confirmation like oh you
that girl that girl as long as that girl
right right that girl you be you're
being nice because i know you want to
say that
have you thought about any of the
performances this year because they're
like i love seeing the collaborations on
the amas and so you got like your girl
mega stallion with bts a new addition
and new kids on stage at the same time
are you are you kind of excited about
anybody
i am excited i'm i'm excited to see bts
i know my daughter she she loves bts i
like her to listen to bts because you
know they're like more like friendly and
they make her dance and all that stuff
so i know she's gonna be excited to see
them i'm excited to see my girl megan
i'm excited to see chloe bailey
still sonic i'm excited to see bruno
mars he's such a great performer that'll
be good show
[Music]